Dút vật giống rau đẹp dọn lấy tiền xeong,
nguyễn lề khôi 8 bây tuổi, bị công an tạm giữ để điều tra.
Tối bệnh năm, cập vật trong ở Lai Châu,
đi sẽ khác từ bắt nình xuống bên xe miệnh để bắt quốc xe về nhà.
Tại đây, khôi cùng một ai sẽ khác tiếp tận,
nói sẽ chờ vật trong xa điểm, có sẽ khác đi Lai Châu.
Khi đến khu vực gần khu công nghiệp bắt thang lòng,
khôi yêu cầu vật trong trả năm trong đi động tiệt xe.
Sau đó, lấy lý dò hai người mang nhiều hành lý,
người này tiếp tục lỗi thêm hai chăm gì đâu.
Bì phản ứng vị cho rằng mức giả qua cao,
khôi lớn tiền đẹp ra, giúp một vật giống rau đẹp viết người chồng.
Sau khi lấy được tiền, tại sẽ nhánh chống dở khỏi hiện chờ.
Phóng đường từ bên xe miệnh đến khu vực trên dài khoảng 12 kí lume,
giá xe máy trên một số những dụng rau đậu bột mười đến tảm ơn đến đậu tuổi thời điểm.
Thấp hơn sau về su tiền mà cập vật trong phải chả.
Ngày tám thẳng năm, công an đã tạm giữ khôi để điều tra về hành vi cưỡng đó tại xan.